[Musica]
le barriere i muri se ne parla esistono
li troviamo attorno a noi
soprattutto penso che i ragazzi che
hanno la maturità in questi giorni ce
l'abbiano frasi in testa come terrore
come tema d'esame chiaramente non
azzeccheranno ormai una previsione stata
azzeccata sugli argomenti ma le barriere
ce le troviamo spesso davanti le creiamo
certe volte ci troviamo noi ha nemmeno
vederle a considerarle quasi inevitabili
quasi scontate
capita anche che le vediamo magari
create dagli altri ma che non ti danno
fastidio
oppure le creiamo noi stessi oppure le
consideriamo normali ma le barriere non
sono mai normali le barriere ci isolano
non ci proteggono
se pensate che una barriera possa
proteggervi sì magari da quella falsa
sensazione di autarchia quella zona di
comfort quel piccolo castelletto dorato
quella piccola fortezza in cui noi ci
sentiamo tranquilli gli altri da fuori
vedono il muro vedono un bell'ambiente
vedono un muro ben dipinto ma tutto si
ferma lì pensiamo alle barriere che
magari vediamo nell'immagine del genere
e non ne ha è un panorama non vediamo
con fini non vediamo barriere se
guardassimo queste immagini dal
satellite delle nostre montagne le
nostre colline non vedremmo delle
barriere
se guardiamo la cartina vediamo delle
righe tirate magari da storici politici
cartografi pensatori artificiali certe
volte ma che creano ostacoli
quindi cosa possiamo fare a questo punto
per dire qualcosa qualche barriera la
possiamo superare vale la pena farla
vediamo che magari in qualche caso è un
aiuto è un'incitamento una soddisfazione
superare le barriere arrivati più o meno
effettivamente la mia età media
chiamiamola così qualche trucchetto
effettivamente me lo sono anch'io
inventato nel lavoro nella vita privata
e anch'io magari come un po tutti magari
ho costruito creato qualche ostacolo
melo sono creato qualche ostacolo arrivi
in certi momenti in cui magari
l'insoddisfazione il senso di impotenza
anche nel lavoro ti dice beh questa
barriera la devo superare devo fare il
salto devo superare anche i timori le
remore che io stesso magari o è una
prova
chi si butta fa un salto e magari dice
vabbè guarda non era poi così brutta
come sembrava questa cosa e uno inizia a
caricarsi la mia stata un'idea balzana
che era da un po di tempo che mi girava
in testa ne parlavo magari a cena con
gli amici ti metti a chiacchierare e non
perché magari abbia degli amici
particolarmente ben disposti o
accondiscendenti nei miei confronti ma
mi dicevano ai prova buttati perché non
puoi provare a parlare a un certo punto
uno si decide si va si butta vizia
lavorarci a metterci la passione
l'impegno l'entusiasmo e ti butti
chiaramente lungo il cammino raccogli
gli entusiasti raccogli quelli che ti
danno carica raccoglie i anche i critici
i critici sono quelli che poi alla fine
ti presentano delle barriere a cui
magari tu non avevi neanche pensato che
sono anche quelle molto importante il
mio salto della barriera lavorativo non
è proprio stato semplicissimo e arrivo
da un mondo delle telecomunicazioni
dell'informatica delle grandi
multinazionali e sono passato turismo
apparentemente parlandone con tutti i
giorni è fortunato e più divertente più
simpatico
stai all'aria aperta sì è vero è chiaro
che fra una scrivania un monitor
e girare per le campagne è una bella
cosa ma quello che è successo e che ho
raccolto storie
ho incontrato gente ho raccolto storie
di gente che ha superato affrontato
barriere proprie del territorio delle
persone attorno a sé
io sono di torino ma ho forti radici qua
nelle nostre colline con ferrato
monferrato alessandrino astigiano langhe
le conosco bene e per i motivi che c'è
alle spalle della mia idea ha ben deciso
di partire qua di iniziare a lavorare su
questi territori perché perché il
piemonte ma non solo piemonte ha
soprattutto nel mondo del turismo
risorse inesplorate risorse importanti
risorse umane importanti risorse umane
di gente che ha idee che appassioni che
ha voglia di fare qualcosa per il
territorio per sé e per creare una rete
ho incontrato storie molto belle ma
quelle più di successo quelle più
importanti erano quelle di persone che
hanno aperto aziende agrituristiche
biodinamiche di grande successo tenute
agricole molto belle sono diventati
apicultori hanno aperto attività di
servizio per i turismi proveniendo
nemmeno dalla campagna provenendo dalla
città proveniendo dal lavoro di
dirigente in banca dirigenti di aziende
informatiche responsabili marketing
attori di soap opera da un certo punto
hanno visto delle barriere davanti a sé
nella vita nel lavoro e ha deciso di
superarle e di dimostrare agli altri che
possibile si sono aperti al territorio
hanno cercato di creare reti di
inserirsi nella comunità del territorio
poi andando nel territorio e conoscendo
e parlando con le persone vedi che ci
sono altre cose quelle che diciamo che
sono piccolo è bello
il tour è bello sì ci sono delle piccole
realtà stupende ben fatte sia in termini
umani che proprio magari fisici sociali
oppure territoriali
piccolo è bello ma certe volte fa
rimanere piccolo mantiene piccolo non
crea comunità vera e propria il piccolo
certe volte alla base una paura magari
alla base magari la paura che ci rubino
quella piccola idea e il vicini
conoscano quello che noi abbiamo
protetto e costruito e che quindi l'anno
prossimo facciano qualcosa del genere
oppure che quei 12 turisti vadano da
loro e non noi magari pensiamo alla
proliferazione dei di sagra in certi
periodi dell'anno
va benissimo la gente ha possibilità di
uscire ma a un certo punto spetta
parliamone
forse se ci mettiamo d'accordo riusciamo
a fare qualcosa di veramente bello
interessante ho raccolto decine di
aneddoti e di cose strane mi viene in
mente per esempio bella un proprietario
di un agriturismo di un bed and
breakfast nelle nostre colline
mi diceva guarda i turisti vengono qua
per la prima volta vedono questa
valletta un paese dall'altra parte mi
chiedono informazioni mi chiedono come
si chiama mi chiedono cosa succede e
cosa c'è da vedere quali sono le
manifestazioni le attività e io mi
arrangio mi dice cerco di fare il
possibile ma non sempre su tutte le cose
che capitano per un motivo semplice
perché oltre a valletta c'è un'altra
provincia oppure è capitato un altro
paese di 400 abitanti incontrando le
persone mi dicono sai qua ci sono ben
tre associazioni che fanno attività
culturali eventi su questo paese facendo
un po di ponti 400 abitanti togli i
giovani in pascoli bambini
disinteressati gli anziani quelli che
lavorano via quelli che non sono
residenti perché la seconda casa alla
fine rimangono 10 12 persone magari per
l'associazione e quindi piccolo magari
bello ma rimane piccolo poi c'era forse
l'avete visto su internet quel video
virale proprio della barriera classica
poi cancello scorrevole con i cani che
si abbaiavano due gruppi di cani che si
abbaiavano fortissimo il cancello
continuava a scorrere nel momento in cui
cancello sia aperto perfettamente i cani
sono girati e sono andati via
e questo è quello che capita
la barriera ci crea questa sensazione di
sono forte sono bello ma poi nei momenti
in cui devo comunicare veramente capita
qualcosa di diverso quindi pensiamo al
contrario invece pensiamo a quello che
può unire e non separare pensiamo alle
nostre colline al nostro territorio ecco
ho parlato di langa e monferrato
pensiamo ai turisti che vengono qua e ti
facciamo vedere le colline magari li
parliamo di alta langa bassa langa alto
monferrato basso monferrato facessimo un
sondaggio
probabilmente i confini non sono chiari
ma i nomi spesso sono ben noti pensiamo
però allora a questo punto ha come
possiamo unire quello che certe barriere
virtuali o reali hanno diviso
pensiamo appunto ai sentieri dalle
strade ai percorsi ciclabili ai percorsi
per l'equitazione
pensiamo ai corsi d'acqua anche quando
non fanno danni
pensiamo alle ferrovie alle ferrovie
dismesse ma soprattutto pensiamo al
capitale umano alle persone che sono sul
territorio con le loro passioni con le
loro voglie pensiamo un artigiano che
magari non vuole che il proprio lavoro
il proprio sapere per la conoscenza si
disperda sarebbe ben lieto di insegnare
a una famiglia danese una piccola arte
pensiamo a un arbori sta che conosce le
erbe della zona e quindi fa conoscere il
territorio proprio per poterle poterlo
vivere meglio
pensiamo non lo so un fotografo che
conosce bene la propria borgata al
proprio angoli e porta magari turisti a
fare le foto particolare un po uniche
pensiamo all insegnante di yoga che
magari invece di stare in una palestra
rende una vigna un'oasi di pace
l'astronomo dilettante appassionato che
porta nell'angolo buio della borgata
della frazione dei turisti a guardare le
stelle che in città non sono visibili
pensiamo a quindi a queste cose che ci
uniscono pensiamo a come presentiamo il
territorio presentiamo la nostra terra
presentiamo le nostre colline
un turista quando guarda un panorama
come questo e come ce ne sono tanti
dalle nostre parti non vedi con fini ma
non li vuol vedere non ha interesse di
sapere cosa finisce come mai non si
comunica cosa capita rivede la bellezza
di quello che c'è proviamo quindi a fare
questo salto
proviamo a fare il salto che ci fa
passare a dire mi metto a disposizione
della comunità creo questa rete attorno
a me faccio in modo che il mio piccolo
si unisca agli altri per crescere il
mondo del turismo fortunatamente in
italia è un mondo fortunato abbiamo a
disposizione una marea di cose già
pronte abbiamo la natura
abbiamo i beni culturali abbiamo il
nostro territorio nel suo complesso ma
era l'elemento umano quello che lega
veramente territorio e abbatte le
barriere è l'elemento umano è
sicuramente l'ingrediente fondamentale
per abbattere le barriere
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]